Let's summarize what we've been talking about for the past few quizzes. We
started with a function, f of x equals x minus 5 times x plus 3. We figured
out, it's two factors are these two quantities inside parentheses. That told us
that the x coordinates of the x intercepts are 5 and negative 3, and these two
numbers are the same as the zero's, or the roots of the function. Let's see if
we can fill out all this information for a new function. This time we have f of
x equals x minus 2 times x plus 7 times x minus 1. Please tell me what the
factors of this function are, what the x coordinates of it's x intercepts are
and what the 0s are. Notice I've already written an x equals here for you. So,
in the zero box, I'd like you to just write, the values that x needs to equal
in order for the function to equal zero. In each of these three boxes, please
separate your answers by commas.